[Musique]
le fait que quand vous ne soyez pas dans
tpm pays où quand vous êtes moins
d'appeler c'est vrai que moi je me rends
pas compte et je vais vous le dire
franchement vous et c'est vrai que
paraît que c'est compliqué et gilles
vont parfois série que vous rester trois
mois sans faire l'émission est ce que
vous êtes
voilà vous êtes en ra sera ou pas du
tout parce que je vous jure que c'est
vrai mais en fait je fais des missions
bien sûr je pense à vous et j'essaie de
vous appeler d'honorer les messages tout
ça mais c'est vrai que voilà c'est je
sais que ça peut être extrêmement
compliqué moralement c'est pas du tout
la même chose c'est pas du tout la même
vie que quand on fait les missions et
quand on ne la fait pas ça c'est vrai on
vit différemment et comme moi je vis
professionnellement pour vous presque à
100 vers sinon je reste intégralement
c'est vrai que quand on n'est pas là on
se demande quand on va être appelé si on
va être appelé donc c'est un certain
c'est vrai que c'est un certain et c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile à vivre je
suis ému en le disant parce que en fait
y'a tellement d'implication quand on est
là tellement on est à 100% moi je suis à
fond vous le savez du matin au soir
et quand on n'est pas là du coup marié
un grand vide mais un vide littérale le
vide de ne pas bosser et le vide humain
de pas voir les gens et de se dire mais
à quoi ma journée va être utilisé en
tout cas c'est vrai qu'on a cette
habitude maintenant quasi quotidienne
d'être là le soir à l'heure après
l'arrêt c'est toujours pareil sont les
questions personnelles
personne n'est sûr de soi autour de
cette table on est tous humble et la
question de temps en temps c'est dire
est ce que c'est une punition ou
pourquoi est ce que j'ai pas été mon
esclave et voilà on se remet en question
et on voit moins bien évidemment
reviendra peut-être plus tard
objectivement c'est vrai que c'est une
famille et c'est vrai que quand on n'est
pas loin du maire faisait bien le truc
qui n'a pas plu ou d où j'ai été chiant
où les gens ne viennent plus parce qu'il
ya vous et les gens on dit que peut-être
que les gens nous aiment plus qu est ce
qui m a jamais mais moi je veux du
travail je voulais les derniers on sait
moins vu parce qu'il y avait un
confinement il m'a dit qu'il y avait
quatre personnes n'étaient pas sur les
missions et moi je les ai vécus très
très mal et on se pose beaucoup de
questions c'est vrai c'est une vraie
angoisse et on se dit qu'est ce qu'on a
fait de mal qu'est ce qu'on n'a pas fait
d'amis mais c'est très vrai rien fait de
mal c'est vraiment voilà c'est aussi
voilà ccc voilà les missions parfois
vous avez vu l'émission elle a plein de
visages
j'aimerais voilà et est plein de visages
différents donc quelquefois on a besoin
de visages
deux tailles de tels profils d'autres
profils donc forcément quand on n'est
pas appelée autour de la table c'est à
dire je vous aime pas non mais bien sûr
que non mais sauf qu'on le prend parfois
on se remet en question sur di castro
n'a pas bien fait est ce qu'on n'a pas
fait une bonne émission ou n'être qu on
n'a pas parlé
enfin on n'a pas parlé en long moment
voilà dont on doute et ça nous ça nous
remet aussi un petit coup de pression je
pense je considère toujours que c'est
fini demain savent que je sais qu'on a
de la chance d'être là on a la chance
d'être payés pour donner notre avis sur
un plateau moi je me considère souvent
pas légitime et j'ai l'impression d'être
un imposteur dont je me dise que je
prends ce qu'il ya à prendre et moi j'ai
toujours fait en sorte d'avoir trois
boulots de quatre boules en même temps
par peur d'avoir rien en fait
emotionnellement c'est vraiment pas
facile parce qu'on se demande
effectivement pourquoi ça n'a pas ça n'a
pas aussi bien fonctionné et je suis
content je suis revenu en invité ça a
bien marché mais comme guillaume aussi
je me dis ça peut s'arrêter demain il
vaut mieux le prendre comme ça en fait
l'acteur qui monte je vous dis la vérité
jean-michel mairie de meaux claouey
aujourd'hui vrai voilà et brive on me
manque un monde ailleurs je vois là il
va revenir vite j'ai appelé la syrie qu
ils sont excellents les deux voilà donc
voilà je le dis et c'est pas des
sanctions voilà on essaie de faire
tourner